a new Consumer Reports investigation out
just this morning finds that there may
be more mercury in canned tuna than you
realize Consumer Reports found what they
called unpredictable spikes of mercury
levels in five popular canned tuna
brands you see them on your screen and
they say that pregnant people may be
best off avoiding tuna all together now
we should mention that these mercury
levels are within FDA standards which
currently say that pregnant people can
eat canned tuna in small quantities we
reached out to all five companies in the
report Chicken of the Sea safe catch
starkist and Wild Planet they say their
products are safe and within FDA
standards bumblebee did not get back to
us in time for you for this report for
more on all of it let's bring in CBS
News medical contributor Dr David agus
Dr Aegis good morning to you uh before
we get into some of these
recommendations what are the risks of
eating canned tuna
well you know Mercury is a compound that
affects neurodevelopment and so it's a
neurotoxin so if you have a high Mercury
level while the brain is developing in a
fetus there can be cognitive issues
later in life so we're very cautious in
a developing brain so that is young
children and pregnant women especially
need to keep Mercury away from those
neurons that are developing
and I guess I should clarify it's not
necessarily canned tuna that is the
issue this can be in any kind of tuna
and not only tuna right other fish as
well
yeah so Mercury is an impurity and coal
and when you burn coal Elemental Mercury
goes to the the clouds and then it rains
and then when it comes down into the
ocean bacteria converted to
methylmercury these bacteria are deep
fish heated and then large fish eat the
smaller fish and that's how they
accumulate Mercury and so it's the
larger fish and the deeper fish where
you get the Mercury swordfish tuna and
other big deep fish have higher levels
of mercury very little mercury for
example in salmon and trout and other
smaller fish that are at the surface Dr
Aegis it's David forgive my ignorance
but can you cook it out so to speak like
I love a tuna steak right so is that in
some ways safer than let's say uh canned
tuna off the shelf
it sounds almost like a song can you
cook it out
um unfortunately no is that the the
elements in that food stay there and
they're very stable to heat so we can't
remove it and what this report showed is
that while light tuna has much less
Mercury than other tuna it's variable
and you're going to get a batch here and
there with a higher level and so while
the FDA is correct that we don't really
know the level that can cause
neurodevelopment issues and these are
probably safe why take that risk you
know a developing baby you want to give
them a chance so they can actually
develop normally eight percent of
pregnant women in the United States have
a Mercury level that may affect the
brain development of the child and
they're predominantly wealthy women who
can afford and buy fish all the time so
we have to be aware of it so Dr agus if
I was your patient and I am what would
you tell me how much tuna can I eat
should I eat are you because he's not
supposed to say that on air David I know
I know there you go
so you can have one to three servings a
week of tuna and as an adult it would be
very safe you know try to stick to the
light tuna if you can but the key is you
know don't it's moderation don't have it
every day which some people do but you
really need to have moderation one to
three a day a week I'm sorry
it real quickly Dr I guess is there any
treatment if you do get a higher
exposure level
David it's a great question is that it's
just you know you abstain from it and if
you abstain from fish with Mercury it
will go away over several weeks so there
are no pills there's no chelation it
goes away naturally and it's clear from
the body
well I will not be abstaining I like my
tuna with Pickles Mayo olive oil and
lemon all of it in there a little Dill
salt and pepper it is delicious
moderation of course Dr Aegis thank you
very much